[Música]
tras la validación en la duma Este
martes el senado ruso aprobó por
unanimidad las leyes que ratifican los
tratados de anexión unilateral a Rusia
de las regiones lugans gerson
el presidente de Irán ibrahimsy acusó a
Estados Unidos y a Israel de estar
detrás del movimiento desatado por la
muerte de maxa
acusaciones que ya formuló el ayatolá
alija menei se cumplen más de dos
semanas desde el fallecimiento de la
joven tras ser detenida por la policía
de la moral y del inicio de las
protestas
el premio Nobel de física de 2022 fue
atribuido en partes iguales a Alan azbek
John floser y anthonynger por sus
descubrimientos en mecánica cuántica
analizaremos la importancia de sus
hallazgos con nuestra especialista en
ciencia y salud más Romero sala
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Rusia porque
tras la validación ayer en la cámara
baja en la duma Este martes el senado
ruso aprobó las leyes de ratificación de
los tratados de anexión a Rusia de las
regiones de doniesk lugans gerson y
saporia recordemos que el pasado viernes
el presidente Vladimir Putin firmó Los
acuerdos de integración con Los líderes
prorrusos de estos territorios después
de un proceso de referendos no
reconocidos por la comunidad
internacional sin embargo el ministro de
exteriores rusos serguéi labroz reiteró
que para Moscú no tiene importancia el
reconocimiento de occidente nuestro
corresponsal en Rusia Xavier collage con
todos los detalles
después de que la maquinaria legal rusa
hablase la maquinaria legal legislativa
culmina hoy la anexión de los cuatro
territorios ucranianos ocupados en este
momento parcialmente por las tropas
rusas luans y también las nuevas
conquistas de Putin de jerson y
saborilla aún así las fronteras
occidentales de Rusia Siguen sin estar
claras en un momento en el que el
ejército ucraniano Está realizando
nuevos avances no solo en la región de
doñets sino también en jerson donde las
tropas ucranianas van empujando poco a
poco hacia el sur hasta acorralar a los
soldados rusos el presidente ucraniano
Por cierto golodín y selenski ha dicho
que entra en vigor su decisión de
prohibir como si fuese un asunto de
seguridad nacional establecer
conversaciones o negociaciones con Rusia
mientras Vladimir Putin sea presidente
aquí en Moscú sigue adelante el
reclutamiento no solo entre personas con
que hayan hecho el servicio militar sino
también con personas sin experiencia
Aunque lo ha dimir Putin ha prometido
corregir los errores del principio
cambiamos de información porque igual
que hizo ayer el líder supremo de Irán
el
hoy el presidente iraní Ibrahim Racing
acusó a Estados Unidos y a Israel de
organizar las protestas por la muerte de
maxa Amin recordemos que la joven murió
tras ser detenida por la policía de la
moral y que fue el mismo día de su
funeral el 17 de septiembre cuando se
desató el movimiento contra la represión
y la brutalidad del régimen de Teherán
reisy pidió unidad nacional mientras las
protestas se extienden por los centros
educativos del país escuchemos las
palabras del presidente iraní
[Música]
porque los enemigos porque Estados
Unidos y el régimensionista conspiraron
contra nuestra nación nuestro país y
nuestra Revolución y crearon estos
disturbios como dijo el líder supremo
nuestro país Está avanzando y los
enemigos no quieren que nuestro país
progresen
cambiamos de nuevo de información Corea
del Norte disparó un misil balístico
sobre Japón por primera vez en cinco
años como respuesta Tokio activo su
sistema de alerta antimisiles y emitió
una inusual advertencia para que la
población buscara Refugio los detalles
en el siguiente informe
era una mañana normal en Japón hasta que
ocurrió esto
tenemos noticias de última hora el
gobierno japonés advierte que Corea del
Norte parece haber lanzado al menos un
misil balístico existe la posibilidad de
que se dirija a Japón el gobierno está
llamando a todos en el país a permanecer
en el interior o encontrar un refugio
inmediatamente
en todo Ja pequeños pueblos y grandes
ciudades sonaron las sirenas
[Música]
junto con un mensaje ominoso
un misil ha sido lanzado Corea del Norte
parece haber lanzado un misil
mensajes de advertencia llegaron a los
teléfonos los trenes de alta velocidad
se detuvieron abruptamente con el mismo
mensaje repetido en bucle
[Música]
se dio el visto bueno unos 20 minutos
después el misil cayó en el Pacífico
pero el daño estaba hecho el país estaba
sacudido y enfadado
vivo en un apartamento Así que no tengo
sótano cuando me dijeron que me pusiera
cubierto bajo tierra mi reacción sincera
fue realmente no sé qué hacer aunque no
haya sanciones quiero que el gobierno
adopte una postura más firme frente a
Corea del Norte
[Música]
me sentía asustada si su tecnología ha
mejorado significa que están trabajando
en ello a diario Me preocupa que algún
día puedan fabricar un misil potentes
fue la primera vez que un misil
norcoreano sobrevoló Japón desde 2017
las autoridades calificaron en el
disparo como un acto imprudente y
dijeron que la distancia de vuelo
estimada de este misil en particular Era
la más larga entre los cohetes lanzados
anteriormente
vamos ahora a Francia porque ahí aumenta
la polémica por la acusación contra el
ministro de Justicia Eric dupont moetib
por presunto conflicto de intereses al
abusar supuestamente de su cargo para
ajustar cuentas contra adversarios de su
antigua carrera como abogado sin embargo
dupont mavety descarta renunciar y
asegura que cuenta con la confianza de
la primera ministra Elizabeth born los
detalles con nuestra periodista en París
Erika olavarría el ministro de Justicia
francesa que por ahora no está en la
orden del día una posible renuncia su
cargo ni siquiera después de que ayer la
corte de justicia de la República lo
enviara nuevamente frente a los
tribunales en un caso por conflicto de
intereses de su época cuando era abogado
sus acusadores dicen que
ha utilizado su cargo como ministro para
ajustar cuentas con jueces que lo
habrían perjudicado en su época como
jurista él dice que cuenta con la
confianza de la primera ministra algo
que confirmó el gabinete de Elizabeth
born Y además que es un justiciable como
cualquier otro que sí debe ir a los
tribunales lo hará y contará su versión
sin embargo esta polémica ha opacado la
idea de República ejemplar que quería
crear Emmanuel macron sobre todo después
de que ayer se supiera que el secretario
general del palacio del inicio
alexiquela también está haciendo
encausado en una investigación por
conflicto de intereses en su caso Keller
que además fue el jefe de gabinete de
Manuel macron cuando era ministro de
economía está siendo investigado por los
vínculos que tiene con una empresa
armadora suizo italiana que es propiedad
de la familia de su madre esta empresa
era cliente de un armador francés que es
una empresa pública y de cuyo directorio
formaba parte del éxito cuando Él
trabajaba en el Ministerio de economía
francés
vamos con información de nuestra región
en Ecuador ayer lunes al menos 15
personas murieron y otras 21 resultaron
heridas en un nuevo motín carcelario los
hechos ocurrieron en el penal de
cotopaxi número 1 cerca de la ciudad de
latacunga en el centro del país con las
víctimas registradas ayer el número de
presos fallecidos en las cárceles de
Ecuador en 2022 se acerca al centenar
y este martes se conoció el nombre de
los premiados con el Nobel de física
2022 se trata de Alan aspect John floser
y anthonynger que fueron reconocidos por
sus descubrimientos en el ámbito de la
mecánica cuántica y para entender las
dimensiones de sus hallazgos contamos de
nuevo con el análisis de nuestra
periodista especializada en ciencia y
salud más Romero sala Buenos días Buenos
días Rosa Entonces por qué se atribuyó
este premio a partes iguales este Nobel
de física a estos tres científicos
empezando haciendo una incisión Y es que
son tres hombres de nuevo solo cuatro
mujeres han recibido el premio de Nobel
de física en el a toda la historia de
esta premiación pero básicamente estos
tres científicos lo que hicieron fue
construir a base de los experimentos que
fueron haciendo uno tras otro no
compartiendo esta información para
demostrar en el mundo real no solo en la
teoría varias cosas relacionadas con la
física cuántica primero por ejemplo que
las leyes de la naturaleza efectivamente
obedecen a este particular pues campo
Público de la física no la física
cuántica es lo que aparece cuando vimos
que las leyes Pues que conocíamos de la
física clásica como la gravedad por
ejemplo no aplicaban cuando se
intentaban llevar al nivel más pequeño
al nivel atómico al nivel subatómico y
allí se descubrieron cosas
verdaderamente sorprendentes por ejemplo
que las partículas existen en el llamado
estado de incertidumbre todas sus
propiedades no no tienen un valor
concreto sino que existen en un amplio
amplio abanico de probabilidades y al
observarla al medirla al intervenir de
esta forma es que se concreta un valor
Entonces estos científicos gracias a
varios experimentos demostraron que eso
efectivamente no sucede solo en la
teoría sucede en el mundo real y por
ejemplo Pues básicamente eso demuestran
en esta práctica con tradición de
postulados de físicos tan relevantes por
ejemplo como Einstein que era un gran
opositor de esta teoría hace décadas y
mar esto nos lleva a hablar de
partículas entrelazadas que significa de
una forma que lo podamos entender todo
Sí verdaderamente parece magia para mí
es una de las cosas más mágicas que
tiene este campo de investigación y es
que todos estos experimentos que
hicieron para demostrar esa pues estado
de incertidumbre venían de pares no
entre dos partículas que como decías tú
están entrelazadas las partículas
recordemos son esas partes como pues
diminutas de los átomos por ejemplo un
fotón o un electrón y pueden existir se
han demostrado en Estados compartidos
eso qué significa que cuando uno mide
una propiedad de una partícula en
concreto eso tiene un impacto en la otra
y puede saber el valor de esa propiedad
en otra partícula a pesar de que esté
lejos de que no estén cerca Entonces se
comportan de una forma compartida No eso
además también demuestra que no sucedió
solo a través de unas variables ocultas
que se decía en un momento que podía
suceder eso no que había unas variables
ocultas que no sabíamos determinar no
sabemos ahora que eso ocurre mediante
esa incertidumbre Pues teorizada por la
física cuántica y además los científicos
no solo eso que ya suficientemente
sorprendentes sino demostraron que se
pueden comunicar transmitir información
entre esas pa no cuando una partícula
está entrelazada y se contacta con otra
se transmite esta información sin
necesidad de ningún tipo de señales de
cable de nada e incluso pueden viajar No
aquí por ejemplo vemos unas unos pares
de partículas no cuando una partícula de
este par choca con otra se transmiten la
información y Eso provoca que la uno y
la cuatro por ejemplo compartan esta
información sin que hayan tenido que
interactuar nunca y más para llevarlo un
poco a lo que podría ser nuestro día a
día sus hallazgos que nuevas
posibilidades abren en términos de
tecnologías de la comunicación pues Es
verdaderamente un campo revolucionario
no Eso significa como decíamos que una
cosa recibe una señal otras la misma la
recibo la puede transmitir incluso a
kilómetros de distancia y gracias a
estas investigaciones por ejemplo china
en 2020 logró mandar una clave secreta
escrita Precisamente en partículas
entrelazadas concretamente en fotones
desde un satélite que orbitaba pues la
tierra hasta las instalaciones
terrestres también se habla la
computación o cuántica de máquinas más
potentes de las que conocemos ahora o
incluso pues de la posibilidad de
comunicaciones encriptadas Muchísimas
gracias Pues para acercarnos y hacernos
entender un día más la importancia de
todos estos hallazgos que han sido
reconocidos y que van siendo reconocidos
con los premios Nobel un gusto Rosa
nosotros cambiamos de información porque
París ha decidido unirse a otras
ciudades francesas para boicotear el
mundial de Qatar de fútbol el boicot es
una protesta contra la violación de
derechos humanos y el desmedido y
negativo impacto medioambiental que ha
supuesto la organización de este evento
en Qatar pero la medida no está exenta
de polémica
la Euforia colectiva la tensión de
animar a su selección en medio de una
multitud de personas las zonas de
aficionados son sinónimo del mundial
Pero esta vez en muchas ciudades
francesas dicen que no habrá pantallas
gigantes ni concentraciones masivas las
razones para el boicot son muchas hubo
un aumento de estás especialmente
después de que un artículo de 2021
publicado en el diario usgardien
afirmará que más de 6.500 trabajadores
inmigrantes habían perdido la vida en la
construcción de los estadios de Qatar
Además del historial medio Oriental
negativo del país que acoge el mundial y
del coste energético de las zonas de
aficionados O sea que manifestación
estos acontecimientos estarían en total
conflicto con la sobriedad energética
que exigimos a nuestros ciudadanos
el país del Golfo debe climatizar sus
enormes estadios en el desierto para
muchas ciudades francesas la ubicación
de la Copa no tiene sentido desde el
punto de vista medioambiental la
alcaldesa de lille escribió en Twitter
que su ciudad no verá ni un solo partido
por el coste para el medio ambiente y
las denuncias de violaciones a los
derechos humanos en Qatar pero es esto
suficientemente horrible no solo hay que
boicotear el mundial entonces hay que
cortarle el paso no venderle más aviones
o jets ni comprarle petróleo siempre lo
siempre lo paso mal cuando solo se
boicotean los deportes
Aunque algunos lo consideran un paso
positivo otros han criticado los boicots
por considerarlos hipócritas citando a
París como ejemplo boicotea la copa pero
también ha fomentado la inversión de
Qatar en la capital y hasta ahora no ha
dudado en animar al equipo París
saint-germain de propiedad katari
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en Francia 24.com
[Música]